I guess, I just don't understand why anyone would use spaces over tabs.
Like, if it's all the same, why not just use tabs?
Because it could look different on other people's computers.
Tabs create smaller file sizes, all right?
I run a compression company, trust me, I've devoted my life to minimalizing file sizes.
It's what I do, I mean, I do not get why anyone would use spaces over tabs.
I mean, why not just use Vim over Emacs?
I do use Vim over Emacs.
Oh, God, help us.
Okay, you know what, I just... I don't think this is going to work, I'm so sorry.
I mean like, what, are we going to bring kids into this world with that over their heads?
That's not really fair to them, don't you think?
Kids? We haven't even slept together.
And guess what, it's never going to happen now,...
...because there is no way I'm going to be with someone who uses spaces over tabs.
Richard.
Wow, okay goodbye.
One tab saves you eight spaces.